[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show we
welcome the man who just sat down in the
guest chair his new album the ghost of
Ohio has been out there for you to
consume and enjoy and you definitely
have done that since April he is none
other than andy black good to see you
sir how are you happy stoked to be here
talking about Kidz Bop and the Dalton
and whatnot well let's take it in order
cuz you know what we were just talking
in the television commercial segment I
was at the Kidz Bop concert at the
Hollywood Bowl on Saturday night you saw
that on the marquee I did and I didn't
think that I would be explaining to you
what Kidz Bop actually what you know
here we are but but maybe you're just
trying to pick up on some stuff for your
future live like yeah I mean I chose to
be a little bit more inclusive so I
think Kidz Bop here's what would you or
have you let's put it that way have you
ever ended your concert by firing out of
some sort of cannon tattoos that you
could just no but I have a t-shirt gun
before okay and it was a it was a real
problem so I we were playing it was a
festival in Las Vegas and we bought a
t-shirt gun and I thought this would be
a great idea right and so we loaded
t-shirts in and I didn't realize the
power that a t-shirt gun has at a range
that would say be this close I held it
and I I aimed it at the crowd and it was
down at the barricade and it's a
festival stage so it's not that far okay
but it was a distance that I thought
okay this this will be fine it's a
t-shirt yes and it pelted a person right
in the head oh there was no I mean it's
a t-shirt so there's no damage right but
it looked traumatic and so I put it down
and it's sitting in storage and this has
been five six years now and that's and
that's the story of the Andy black
t-shirt gun it was a one and done
situation yeah and it you know never to
be touched again it's too dangerous I
don't need that kind of power so you put
one of your fans into concussion
protocol is that we're stronger than any
Dalton's arm and that's how we get back
okay so you're originally from
Cincinnati Ohio that's your hometown yes
sir born and raised born and raised
Westside okay the west side of Ohio I
like to specify because the east side is
where the fancy folks are from okay from
the salt-of-the-earth down by the
riverside okay yeah and that's where
you're you Bengals fan right off the bat
Rose grew up very close to where I'm for
like the same neighborhood that I grew
up okay yeah that's so now I know where
you get you just firing things off at
the notice where you picked that up yeah
so huge Bengals fan we went Riverfront
Stadium back on the turf back in the old
days oh boy you know my whole life we
went I went to the first game ever at
Paul Brown Stadium I had a piece of
concrete fall from the roof and hit me
in the head
it's a terrible stadium concrete falling
you at any time they're actually good
enough for you it did my dad wrote the
score of the game we lost the Browns in
a preseason game my dad wrote the score
I still have the piece of concrete
your dad wrote the score of the
preseason game yeah for me it's a piece
of concrete that fell on your head I
don't know we talked I'm a Bengals fan
we don't get joy so like you get like
you get things like concrete falling and
then a memory of it and that's about it
see now so your dad didn't think of like
suing Paul Brown or anything like that
because I mean it's a big fat rich
target
I suppose so yeah okay we just moved on
what do you think of your your Bengals
currently right now you know you know
I'm right now or what my biggest hope is
that I say every year seven and nine or
nine and seven
I won a nine and seven season just
because the joy like I have almost no
expectations and that's really a sad
place to be as a fan yes is to hope for
mediocrity yes because at least you'll
enjoy the season like I'm so far beyond
a playoff victory they don't want to
playoff game since I was months old or a
month old I was one month old the last
time we want to playoff game so I've
never experienced that and we came so
close so many times and there was so
many 2005 this is our year wasn't our
year
I think 2013 we all thought this was our
year I was at the game in 2015 it was my
wife's first time being at a bang
came in a playoff game we were all there
we were 90 seconds away from winning my
dad and I were actually crying in the
rain hugging each other this is the
first time 90 seconds later we lost and
I think at that point during the
meltdown at Paul Brown that was the end
for me I kind of thought well I'll never
get joy so let's just hope for sure
you've tapped out I'm still obsessive to
a point where I I it's unhealthy
but I've also resigned myself to how sad
it's gonna be I mean you never know I
mean the new coach exact Taylor a new
day and I heard that so it's being sets
new I like that I didn't know that I
didn't know that I mean you look just as
young as he is right now I mean you know
how old are you I'm 28 okay yeah you're
not too far off from being the head
coach of the Cincinnati but I hope so I
mean they've never acknowledged my
existence before so maybe I could become
my coaches should yeah gru an offensive
guru defensive guru I am I am neither so
I don't have a skill set okay I was I
won an offensive lineman of the camp
award when I was eight hold our signs so
I suppose I'd be real big on the
offensive line as you can see I don't
look like an often oh I know you you're
slight you look more of a slot receiver
yeah well yes with neck tattoos sure yes
you know and no muscle at all I look
like a slender man laughing that's
called rangy yeah all right that's
called rangy you're gonna lean your lean
and ranging that's what you would be you
know I just I love the team I I it's
it's been an important part of my life
my whole life okay you know with my
family it's same goes with the Reds and
it's just it's part of who I am and so I
wish for the best I want them to win I
love the franchise I just I know that
there's they're a team that many say
they don't prioritize winning yeah so
it's difficult to the fan to try to get
behind a team that doesn't do a lot to
make you excited so I'm hoping that
maybe this year we can recapture at
least something and have an exciting
year Andy black here in the Rich Eisen
show so the Reds what let me just figure
out growing up would you just like a
Barry Larkin guy favorite player that's
it right so you nailed that one right on
the head
they're just trying to figure out you
said you were born in 90 so you're
talking about Eric Davis Eric Davis yes
the boys might be a little too soon that
was right before my time I had I had
Deon I had Eric Davis a little bit I had
I had Bret Boone I had you know I had
obviously Larkin and then Griffey in the
twilight of his career in the Twilight I
was good you're not doing too bad this
year the Reds actually right around 500
which is better than what they anybody's
seen from them over the last several
years it's nice because they did they
did try they brought in exciting players
you know having Puig whether he does
great or not it's exciting to have that
kind of a character in the city really
it's been since Osho Cinco that we had
like a guy you know that was really fun
and entertaining and then now out of
nowhere Derek Dietrich comes along and
has it's been a lot of fun right and and
a beautiful ballpark to there it's just
really something else Maricopa were you
there for the home run derby or no no I
wish I would have been but I was I was
on tour you're on tour and Derek
Dietrich is a somebody that I'm sure
you're into a week I was I was really
excited we went very recently we went to
my friend Kevin took us to a Mets game
at Citi Field and we got to go and we
watch the Reds play the Mets and I was
so excited because Dietrich was playing
Votto was takin a rest that day right
and they had I believe two hits in the
whole game and not only did they lose
but the they lost one to nothing and the
pitcher for the Mets hit the only home
run in the only run of the entire game
the game was over in about 15 minutes
yes yeah Thor yeah now I ask you this
question on the air and I asked it to
you gingerly backstage as well being
from Cincinnati Ohio does that make you
an Ohio State Buckeye fan so I didn't I
didn't go to college so I have no real
allegiance and my parents went to UC
University Cincinnati so I can leave my
if I had a tangential relationship with
the college organization it would be the
Bearcats
I loved Kenyon Martin growing up and and
the the basketball team there the
football team's looking a little bit
better but I have no real I mean I you
know I like Dwayne Haskins I was hoping
the Bengals would draft him just for
something interesting I think you're
speaking for like most Bengals fans yeah
but you know how do I put this because I
know anything I say comes across
is very Michigan Wolverine run it by me
first I'm just gonna say it's just that
you not being having a you know a
college degree or get went to college
any education didn't even finish in high
school nothing that doesn't it doesn't
stop most of Ohio for claiming Ohio
State as their team yeah I'm not from
Columbus though so I don't understand I
mean LeBron isn't from Columbus
he's from Akron I don't claim he didn't
go to college either yeah and he's mr.
diehard Ohio State I mean I'm just
plucking names out of the air and it's
my own uncle went to Ohio State so there
is there is some point of reference
there for me but I actually get mad
about this and this is that recently
during the the run of the Cavaliers for
example Cincinnati started claiming the
Cavaliers like we ever cared about that
which was not a thing and similarly
speaking I think that because it's such
a legacy people we don't get a lot man
we don't like right southern Ohio like
we don't have much joy right so when it
comes to like a football franchise that
does well I can understand let's get
some of that over there let's get some
Buckeyes I love it that's not that far I
hear you I'm a musician Andy Black here
on the Rich Eisen show how'd you get
into music how did you first get started
there my dad was a huge he's in a punk
rock band and he was in to kiss and
Alice Cooper and Motley Crue and I kind
of was introduced to all that at once
and so I thought I'd love to dress up
and make up in costumes and play heavy
music and so that's been my whole career
trajectory is is doing that so if your
dad was into some other type of music
you think he'd have been possibly my mom
was into more singer/songwriter stuff
Bruce Springsteen in particular and Bob
Dylan and stuff so that's where I got my
love for songwriting like I
the thing about kissing stuff for me is
that I didn't like as an eight-year-old
I didn't have any interest in you know
rock and roll all night and party every
day right but you know I thought oh this
is interesting this guy's talking about
something and then as I got older I'd
like to find out what it is
streets of Philadelphia as a kid I
didn't know what that song was about
sure as you get older you find oh that's
interesting so as a songwriter
Springsteen is more important to me and
then as a guy who dresses up and black
leather Alice Cooper was more important
thanks I see so what I saw you dressed
up in the full rock thing by the way
with with Jerry Cantrell well Jerry
Jerry came on and this was paying off a
fantasy football back yeah I don't know
if you wear of the full story but there
I am I'm Lexie Steel's Greta garb which
fit perfectly by the way one off from
for Mary gating image and I'm still
panther right there and Lexi by the way
of your fantastic really nice friend you
do look great they're not as good as him
but fantastic what do you think I mean I
walked around and in pants that normally
I don't walk around in look pretty good
in the pants like you have the legs for
it and that's the problem sometimes
people don't have the legs for it
wow I've never been told that's a big
compliment I have the legs for anything
and you have the legs for Hera medal
honestly no idea by the way you're
seeing me at the Roxy my favorite thing
was you know I they had me out there and
II and the curtains part yes I assume
you have you played the rock okay so you
know what it is and so I'm out there and
I just looked down and let's just say
the people that I would have fired a
t-shirt gun at yes right there it's
dangerous and I just do and one of the
fans was just like looking at me like
who the hell is this guy and I kind of
relished it that a little yeah right
there yeah that was my rush that's a fun
moment to infuriate someone screw in in
stadiums and I'm so excited we're gonna
be with Motley Crue and I received
nothing but that look at the entire
towards the fans of Motley Crue are
there to see Motley Crue not the band
opening so it's us slash and Motley Crue
oh my god were so excited the first day
we're in Munich we're playing in a
stadium we get done with the first song
and there was it was such silence that
it hurt my ears like it wasn't booing it
was just arms crossed indifference and I
thought this is beautiful to try to be
on stage because the the point of a lead
singer is to try to like hype people up
so the songs don't I go alright thank
you
dead silence and then you like how long
do i wait do i go into the next
song do I see if anybody says anything
so I I actually understand that and
enjoy but do you think your years of
being a Bengals fan help do you prepare
you for that more strong silence and
indifference based on the intents of the
games I went to last year yes now you
know Andy Dalton feels either way we
have seen that game last year where I
think there was about 75 people there we
were in the stadium and I'd say this is
a bummer
did you why are you introducing her to
happen in Florida okay she has no
allegiance to any franchise so she's
become a Bengals fan okay oh my gosh yes
so it's a little bit like 2015 we're
going to playoffs all good she's been
real bummed out for the last couple
years and I said this has been most of
my life but this is what you got to get
used to it by the way I think we're you
know look you're clearly successful in
your own right you don't need my help
Andy black but I think right here the
new album is called legs legs legs for
her mouth LEDs legs for her medley
experimental oh and then the first title
or the next the first track is arms
crossed indifference yes I think that
sounds like a great a song yeah that
we're inspired and then we came up with
another one earlier
- okay leg neck tattoo that's named your
fantasy team yes I do it was the last
year's name was a perfect storm perfect
storm was my favorite who's Vaughn tez
was I was a big fan of Vaughn tez in all
of his antics a long time why aren't you
in Cantrell's League I don't know I
haven't been asked I'd have to as the
he's the general manager I'm the owner
and /i week-to-week generally manage you
chose the groceries to death day we are
the reigning champions we are getting
the Vinnie Paul trophy in at some point
right so we're offering you a spot I
would love to have it yeah I would love
to be in and if somehow someway it comes
back we're all full up you'll be part of
our team EPOC all right sounds good to
me
cuz you are you've you I give you the
blue check
you know what the hell you're talking
about anything with a perfect storm you
know he's in Oakland now so yes he is
that what can you tell your fans about
your upcoming tour dates or anything
give them a little bit of a glimpse of
what what they can expect
yes we're uh we're going on tour just in
a few weeks we're doing the rock star
disrupt festival and then we're doing a
couple of warp tour dates going to the
UK and doing a couple weeks there and
then I'm coming back and doing some
one-off show so I'll be out all summer
just go to Andy black socials had Andy
black on everything and you'll you'll
find out all the Infinity Blade comm for
tour dates as well as stream and
download everything that's going on and
you want to you had an app adapting an
appendectomy before your tour is that a
true story yeah just about what three
and a half four weeks ago I actually it
ruptured
so I had to I had to deal with that
whole thing no kidding yeah and then you
and then you going on to or two weeks
later I had a came for a couple days
that was pretty cool now love's
over-the-top dramatics so I bought like
multiple skull canes and things okay
yeah it was over it was way too much I
didn't need it
that's Jerry x-men right yeah I was
hoping to like oblong what I wanted to
do was the Willy Wonka on the first show
and then like surprise good day sir
yeah good day it's with the it's with
the t-shirt gun right now
please make this as stop for whenever
you want I'd love to come back that's
great all right so we're gonna stay in
touch here because we're either gonna
compete with you and Oh or have you
compete against us or or with us
fantastic I mean I was mixing all of my
my prepositions right need someone who
will still take AJ Green number one
overall yeah I don't know mixing now
mixing though okay maybe we're talking
about okay good that gun is a beast mix
it mix in his first for a sneaky late
first round ability and I hope so I
think you know Jonah see if there are
any running back rankings out already
I'll be too soon but other than that
it's got to be a ShowMe situation for a
waiver wire pickup I gotta see you know
but Mixon AJ Green just it's just I'm
aware I know what's going on
I'm not denying it Joe Mixon eith
running back right now I mean eight
eight I mean some good players ahead of
him say Quan Zeke Christian McCaffrey
camara Melvin Gordon makes early David
Johnson makes sense of really we instill
he's gonna be the entire offense based
on what I'm singing I think we drafted
only offensive linemen didn't draft a
single wide receiver we just got John
Ross the the John Ross experiment still
going on and James Conner just saying I
hope John Ross is good I'm hoping I want
him to be good I do too Marvin hated him
so we'll see
Marvin's with the Arizona State now not
a few good luck Marvin Andy black on
Twitter and Instagram great to have you
here next time you got it the ghost of
Ohio go get it right now for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app